la pression ne retombe pas ce dimanche
dans les rues de la capitale
manifestants et forces de l'ordre se
sont affrontés jusqu'au bout de la nuit
les jets de pierres gaz lacrymogènes les
rues de beyrouth s'enflamme
[Applaudissements]
et
une tension plus que palpable ces
dernières 48 heures plusieurs milliers
de manifestants ont pris d'assaut la
place des martyrs en lieu de
rassemblement traditionnel à beyrouth le
qg de l'association des banques a été
vandalisé certains protestataires ont
infiltré le ministère des affaires
étrangères avant de se faire déloger par
l'armée un policier tué et des centaines
de personnes blessées
le peuple libanais on voit un message au
gouvernement message en partie reçu
c'est le point de non retour le top la
fin l'économie s'effondre la crise
économique financière et monétaire
s'intensifie nos familles nos enfants
nos parents et nos amis sont sans abri
habité par le chagrin le désespoir et la
frustration en ce moment décisif nous ne
pouvons qu'avoir une position
patriotique honorable à leurs côtés je
m'excuse auprès du peuple libanais de ne
pas avoir été en mesure de répondre à
ses ambitions et aspirations en raison
des défis difficiles auxquels nous avons
été confrontés la ministre libanaise de
l'information claque la porte
le ministre de l'environnement a annoncé
également sa démission issoire ce week
end plusieurs députés ont décidé de
quitter le parlement notamment ceux du
parti historique chrétien kataëb meurtri
par la mort de leur secrétaire général q
et lors de la double explosion ce
dimanche une quinzaine de chefs d'état
des grandes organisations
internationales comme le fmi la banque
mondiale ou encore la croix rouge se
sont réunis par visioconférence à
l'initiative du président français
libanais est libre fier et souverain et
il appartient aux autorités du pays
d'agir pour que le pays ne sombre pas et
pour répondre
aspire à ce culte que le peuple libanais
exprimons ce moment même légitimement
dans les rues de beyrouth
nous devons tous ensemble tout faire
pour que ni la violence ni le chaos ne
puisse l'emporter reconstruire ce qui a
été détruit et redonner de l'éclat
beyrouth eu demande beaucoup
les besoins sont très importants et ne
devons accélérer pourrait répondre
surtout avant l'arrivée de l'hiver car
la souffrance des citoyens sans abri va
s'accroître à la lumière de toutes ces
situations stressantes
je me suis engagé devant mon peuple à
obtenir justice car elle seule peut
offrir de vraies condoléances aux
familles endeuillées et à tous les
libanais et j'ai également promis que
personne n'est au-dessus de la loi
quiconque est impliqué dans les
explosions seraient tenus responsables
conformément aux lois libanaises
éradiquer la corruption mot d'ordre du
peuple libanais qui entend se
reconstruire avec des futures élections
législatives anticipées décisive
d'ailleurs la communauté internationale
s'est engagée sur une aide humanitaire
de 250 millions d'euros avec un contrôle
des plus strictes